business is slowly picking up at
freetown's main market
on wednesday the country was rocked by
the worst violence since the end of its
11-year civil war
in response the government announced a
reduction in the price of petrol the
third in less than a month
but for shoppers like maria majallo fuel
wasn't the only issue and the
demonstrations did nothing to bring down
the cost of food
just now i want to buy pepe the humans
say it's ten thousand loans i couldn't
buy it because i love the pepper like
three days ago eight thousand and today
is ten thousand so i don't know what the
problem
people here say the prices especially of
food are far higher than most people can
afford just six months ago this cup of
rice was 21 cents now it's 50 more
both traders and buyers lose as a result
making it harder for small traders like
awana
i've been sitting here since morning no
one came to buy that means there is no
money for me and the orphans in my care
the government says it's working to
stabilize prices
government has set up an essential goods
and services committee
headed by the chief minister whose basic
responsibility is to monitor the
monitor availability and the prices of
various essential commodities that
constitute the food basket
but for the inflation isn't the only
problem people have to contend with
transport and rent have also gone up
with inflation exceeding 25 percent
sierra leoneans may have to brace
themselves for more price increases
it's not clear if the government's
latest measures will be enough to
prevent a repeat of this week's violent
protests
ahmed idris al jazeera freetown sierra
leone